[Musique]
envies de lecture avec henry nicolas
bonjour je vous êtes l'auteur de
archives de l'effroi sous-titré une
histoire française c'est selena édition
va en parler peut-être d'abord un petit
mot sur vous pour votre barque ou alors
vous avez fait une thèse de philosophie
et sciences po vous êtes allé ensuite
dans le monde de l'entreprise c'est
assez rare des philosophes dans le monde
de l'entreprise ne s'est pas forcément
un bon point au début mais parce qu'on
ait vu d'un oeil à un peu particulier
mais finalement ça se passe très bien
tomber sur les bonnes personnes au bon
moment au bon moment vous êtes aussi
passionné de culture vous avez présidé
notamment le les rencontres musicales de
loyer
je crois que alors on salue on salue
anne queffélec je crois qu'il en sera
l'invité de l'émission vite notre
marraine d'honneur absolument c'est vrai
qu'on aime beaucoup et puis vous dire il
ya aussi une propriété vinicole alors
c'est dommage qu'on soit pas au
présentiel sinon on aurait on a 20 ans
on
sait quels domaines au public familial
de la région de pomerol d'accord c'est
pas mal
archives de les froisser donc si je ne
fais pas d'erreur c'est votre premier
livre s est ce que cette envie d'écrire
un athée peut-être contrarié par un
parent d des multiples activités jusque
là
je suis effectivement goût pour
l'écriture de ce livre rien en réalité
j'avais dans les tiroirs un certain
nombre de textes j'avais écrit mais
assez longtemps et puis j'ai eu envie à
un moment d'y revenir et en fait le
déclic ça a été un moment on a commencé
à commémorer le centenaire de la guerre
de 14
à ce moment là je me suis mis à
relire ou lire les textes de jeunes voix
notamment et je me suis dit comment est
il possible que nos parents aient pu
survivre à une expérience aussi est
aussi cataclysmique et donc j'ai la
sensation que j'ai eu envie un peu
d'aller à leur rencontre et de faire
cette enquête biographique d'où ces
archives de délai froid vous êtes en
effet aussi un passionné d'histoire
c'est vrai qu'il ya des histoires ya
l'histoire qu'on nous raconte qu on ne
transmet et puis les histoires que ceux
qui nous ont précédés ont vécu est ce
qu'il s'agit de la même histoire
bah il s'agit de la même histoire oui
dans la mesure où il s'agit là de deux
du même imaginaire de la douleur
précisément j'ai voulu essayer de fait
nous ils vont tous avec des archives je
dirais même très bizarre chic chic et
cet imaginaire de la demeure j'ai voulu
aller voir à quoi ils correspondent est
précisément chez moi un chercher mais
chez mes grands parents
et toute cette enquête biographique qui
auraient été arrêtées selon laquelle
biographiques et je dirais presque une
quête est presque une quête j'ose dire
le terme app spirituel
est ce que je me suis rendu compte
qu'ils ont laissée en legs leur propre
histoire et que étant très généreux ils
nous ont proposé ils m'ont proposé de me
saisir de leur histoire et je pense que
c'est à ce que nous allons vers leur
histoire que ce qu'elle peut devenir
éternellement la nôtre la mienne en
l'occurrence a uniquement par le simple
hasard d'une généalogie oui c'est ce que
vous dites d'ailleurs c'est à dire que
c'est en effet une histoire familiale
que vous racontez mais en réalité c'est
une histoire universelle
ce liban d'où le sous titre d'ailleurs
l'histoire française parce que ce qui
m'a intéressé mois dans ses voeux
lorsque je travaille ça a été moins
l'anecdote qui concerne ma propre
histoire familiale
famille c'est plutôt rancourt à elle à
elle elle fait appel à quelque chose de
plus universel et qui finalement a
concerné l'ensemble des millions de
familles qui ont vécu qui ont vécu six
essais de matières premières deuxième
guerre mondiale il ya d'ailleurs et
c'est un peu votre travail ce que ce que
vous je vous cite cette mystérieuse
fidélité qui nous commande de leur
redonner consistance à ces gens qui aura
16 ans est que vécu ça justement quand
on parle de l'histoire on va venir aux
deux personnages principaux et des
guerres qui les ont qui les ont marqués
est-ce qu'on a une sorte de dette envers
ceux qui nous ont précédés oui je le
crois absolument je pense qu on a tout à
fait une dette et c'est précisément nous
sommes redevables de leur existence et
je pense que la moindre des choses que
nous puissions faire leur égard c'est de
leur justement de la re donner
consistance à ce concept ce sont des
gens
qui ont beaucoup vécu et de façon à
temps si on peut parler et je pense que
se retourner vers leur histoire et leur
redonner la parole c'est une façon de la
redonner la consistance qui se doit un
peu fuite dont il était quand il parmi
nous quand il était vivant parce que
c'était une expérience tellement
épouvantable ils ont arrêté de faire
parler et je pense que nous devons nous
avons au moins le devoir leur redonner
consistance à les revivre c'est très
courant d'ailleurs cette impossibilité
parfois d'enfin cette volonté de ne pas
parler on le sait pour les pôles et pour
les autres qui sont revenus parfois des
camps mais c'est vrai aussi pour les
gens qui ont vécu ces guerres il ya
parfois une culpabilité d'avoir survécu
à cette tragédie
absolument c'est exactement ça c'est une
culpabilité d'avoir survécu et et
doudoune ou le fait qu'en effet ils ont
très peu parlé en fait qui a parlé pour
on sait la résistance lorsque après leur
expérience est une expérience
anthropologique limite au bord de la
précarité la plus absolue en dépit de
cela ils ont réussi à se tenir debout et
à parcourir existence sans rien demander
à personne mais de la plus grande
dignité alors tout part de deux photos
retrouvées la première date de 1953 c7
d'hippolyte la deuxième de 69 c'est
celle de paul qui sont hippolyte épaules
lors hippolyte épaules ce sont bien sûr
des personnages de fiction mais surtout
dont j'ai modifié les no 8 et à
l'entente de lecture au sein de ma
famille parce que ce sont eux donnés
temps un peu différent de ce qu'ils ont
été parce que dans ce travail de
recherche d'archivés j'ai retrouvé les
choses j'ai trouvé des textes des objets
mais ces archives ont été aussi
largement assez largement lacunaire il a
donc fallu imaginer ce qu à tel ou tel
moment ils ont pu faire ils ont pu dire
où ils ont plus la façon dont ils se
sont comportés et donc j'ai
volontairement changé leurs traîneaux
parce que ce sont pas exactement les
grands parents mais se sont en même
temps en grande partie des grands
parents non quand il s'agit en été avec
hippolyte épaules de nommer deux grands
parents fantasmer entre guillemets qui
met en valeur
entre le récit drevant a été un
peu pris en étau entre le récit est le
roman voilà la tribune entre le récit
est le roman mais la fiction a été démis
par fictionnel absolument indispensable
parce qu'autrement les archives n'aurait
pas pu revivre elle sera restée un peu
lettre morte si je puis dire c'est à
dire que y'a eu besoin de la chiers de
la fiction pour les animer et pour
redonner vie à la résistance c'est très
intéressant ce que vous racontez sur ces
photos sont des photos qui ont été
prises assez peu de temps pour chacun
d'eux avant l'heure avant leur mort et
qu'est-ce qu'il faut nous disent les
photos que les mots ne nous disent pas
et et qu'est ce que les mots peuvent
nous dire que les photos ne montrent pas
j'ai vécu une photo une photo en soir
pourra pas être assez neutre et la
réalité en fonction du moment été prise
et avec le changement de perspective d
un tout autre sens c'est ce que ces deux
photos ont été prises alors
qu'évidemment il ne le savait pas
quelques mois avant leur mort et c'est
parce que nous savons qu'ils sont morts
un peu après que nous les interprétons
d'une façon tout à fait différente et
qu'elles veulent dire que c'étaient des
hommes étaient au seuil de l'expérience
ultime sans qu'il l'ait suis à saint
jean et ça nous permet de les voir d'un
tout autre
vous l'écrivez quand on parle de la
guerre
on parle de statistiques on parle de
milliers de morts ou de millions de
morts de dates de personnalité mais je
vous cite les visages déglingué des
survivants oppose des formes concrètes à
leurs réalités massive de la guerre et
c'est ça qui fait le coeur de votre
livre
est ce que est ce qu'on les regarde au
fond ou est ce qu on les repousse
parfois ces visages déglingué
à je pense que on peut les regarder avec
une recul parce que d'une espèce de
distance tu donnes nous permet la garder
mais je pense qu au moment même où il
revenait de la guerre c'était des
réalités assez épouvantable et à
certains endroits ont été l'objet de
rejet de la part de leur famille c'est
d'ailleurs l'une des lunes des histoires
où je
vous le voyageur sans visage le voyageur
sans bagage
une pièce de la nouille qui à l'époque
parler de ces revenants même ses
revenants de la guerre qui n'était plus
reconnus par aucune influence
ils sont tous les deux ils pollitt est
pour le pôle
[Musique]
de cette génération qui a connu deux
guerres
et quand les d'ailleurs hippolyte quand
il s'aperçoit que la deuxième guerre va
va démarrer celle de dell de 40
qu'elle est inéluctable et il vous dit
il et mutique au départ un ace qui des
skins désespérance offensif chez ces
gens-là de 2,2 et on pourrait l'être à
moins d'être désespérée de la nature
humaine quand on a vécu c'est comme vous
dites cet effroi
l'idée ce sont des jeunes qui ont eu des
doutes qui ont un moment fait désespérer
de l'humanité effectivement la
camarade et l'autre quand il a compris
qu'il ya deuxième guerre mondiale allait
arriver
nous sommes utilisées mais en même temps
ce sont des gens qui avaient une telle
force un terme
après ces épreuves effroyable ils ont
réussi à continuer leur trajectoire
leurs trajectoires existentielle je
dirais c'est un souci qui est à mon sens
ils sont admis au vol par exemple
va denis favier médecin va aussi devenir
résistant pendant la laddh deuxième
guerre donc ils vont avoir un rôle enfin
[Musique]
résistants d'ailleurs on s'est un peu de
résistance passive au début parce que
c'est essentiellement un médecin et donc
ils soignent de touba
de quel côté ils penchent et mais
effectivement c'est ce sont des gens qui
sont rivés à leurs devoirs des gens qui
avaient un devoir vis-à-vis d'eux-mêmes
et à devoir vis-à-vis des autres ils ont
rempli quoi que cela ait pu le recruter
et puis y ait d'autres personnages alors
on n'a pas le temps d'en parler comme
hector qui est un peu le dépositaire des
souvenirs de deux de ses grands parents
font un qui est peut-être un peu vous
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas
et nathan wynn atari oui effectivement
c'est
moi moi moi parce que c'est il ya une
ligne paris sionnel non en effet je me
suis mis dans la peau du personnage qui
a commission
pour cette formidable récit au fond c c
c'est cette même question c'est de
savoir si si l'histoire est toujours une
histoire passée
une histoire qui ne sait gré a plus ou
au contraire si est peut-être le fait de
la racontez nous montre qu'elle est
importante il faut peut-être de la
connaître mieux je crois que en fait ce
qui est essentiel c'est de s'en souvenir
un peu usant de la mémoire et refus de
l'oubli ce livre parce que c'est une
histoire qui a été écrite en lettres de
sang et il nous appartient à chacun
d'entre nous quelle nouvelle histoire à
nous a écrite en lettres de sang si nous
savons souvenir de ce qui a été leur
expérience à l'eau
merci beaucoup auraient descola donc
voilà il faut absolument lire archives
de l'effroi une histoire française c'est
aux éditions selena et ça nous replonge
évidemment dans cette tragédie de
l'histoire et est au fond de façon très
très présentes papa parle pas le récit
par la vie de ceux qui ont vécu cette
cet effroi la merci beaucoup
[Musique]